so who are the liberals blaming the
Brett Kavanaugh confirmation on the
electoral college yep it's just not fair
and it's so old
those stupid founders just aren't as
smart as Rob Reiner Plus how is it that
states each have two senators New York
and California should have 25 each and
you guys at home
zilch failing that there's always
impeachment can you rule out this idea
of impeaching Kavanaugh this whole
impeachment thing you know what I'm very
focused on the here and now but you
won't rule out in Pietschmann are we
ruling matters not ruling out
impeachment but is that is that is that
a mistake no I mean that we really want
after we just focus on what we need to
do which is we need to get to the balls
truly hmm so you want impeachment why
not just real echt Trump while you're at
it let's not forget the real enemy white
women
the New York Times blames Cavanaugh's
win on gender traitors and that white
women benefit from patriarchy by trading
on their whiteness to monopolize
resources for mutual gain what the hell
does that mean seriously who talks like
that and has a job and so the left
devours its own as rage bots only see
dissent as evil and yet as they sharpen
the pitchforks the Dems still haven't
disowned a vanetti who used women as
stepping stones to the spotlight so it
seems we're at an impasse which is
French for nowhere good one party says
you must believe all allegations the
other says we should presume innocence
until proven guilty on one side are
these women and on the other side this
Dame what's the solution it's simple if
the Democrats believe or prefer belief
over due process then put a ring on it
if you feel that all allegations must be
believed then from here on and Democrats
should believe any allegation against
themselves because 50% of believing is
better than none no process just
punishment for you and the rest of us
idiots will rely on stupid stuff like
evidence in due process makes sense
Democrats become the party of the
pitchfork maybe then we'll believe it's
not just politics
Dagan welcome to the show thank you sir
yes I have an idea we should have an
impeachable imp --ax where everyone gets
to
try to impeach each other it'll be like
human chess I love that idea
but they can't this is why they talk
about impeachment because they have
nothing else their agenda is anti-trump
or even anti-woman mm-hmm I would argue
because what kind of senator is amazing
her onna to sit there and let that that
anchorman coach her lot
he was mansplaining manspreading
but they always overstep the democrats
do they did it with the you know people
were rightly upset about the separations
at the border about families being
separated but then that that goes
immediately to abolishing ice and what
they've done here is an even strikes
even more closely into the core of
American values because as you pointed
out due process has been thrown out the
said the idea of just fairness in this
country has been trampled on and if
you're a man you're guilty until proven
innocent and if you're a woman you just
better shut up and act as a monolithic
group and follow what the Democrats tell
you and people are rejecting that across
the board one I know that you've said
this to me you look at North Dakota
and you'll go why do they have two
senators so you're you what you think
that this is fundamentally unfair right
that that each state has two senators
when they are less populated no no no I
like it I what I don't like is and I
think what I have said to you is that
eighteen percent of the country right
that's it's represented by the majority
of the Senate so in other words 82
percent of American people are not
represented by that majority and I think
a lot of people feel that this is boils
down to tyranny and I think that's the
word that you reciting before but in
this case I think the people who most
enjoy talk of impeachment are
Republicans because it stirs up their
base you're always talking about it you
look at the leadership on the Democratic
side you can go to shoe more you can go
to Pelosi I can keep going they don't
talk about it there are some people and
an element the left flank of the
Democratic Party and here I'm talking
about especially newly elected
there haven't quite been elected yet but
winners on the Democratic side like
Alexandria Ocasio Cortez Alicia Presley
up in Massachusetts who say hey listen
it's time for the Democrats to be as
strong as consistent as bullish as you
saw from Mitch McConnell when he just
ran over everybody held a Senate seat
open I'm sorry Supreme Court seat open
despite the fact that you had a twice
elected president that's one o'clock one
to me so I'm just saying if the
Republicans play hardball you and you
get people on the left especially coming
up and say hey Democrats stop being so
squishy go after those Republican and
then you end up with an avenatti who
actually goes too far and destroys your
party Dana I bet you have a good point
about why the Electoral College is
important and why people who don't like
it it's really a classist argument
because they want they want to rely on a
metropolitan candidate at the expense of
small towns rural areas where you're
from right yes as two senators but only
one representative in the house in the
house so I've done a little bit of work
on this because I keep seeing it pop up
over and over again it started in for me
I really noticed it in 2003 gore like
this is unfair Alexandria Ocasio Cortez
who want just mentioned she tweeted this
weekend that the electoral college is
actually racist she suggested that the
founding fathers wanted to protect
slavery and that's why they came up with
the idea of the electoral college that
is not true no there is no evidence of
that at all and besides Abraham Lincoln
yeah who was president that ended
slavery right he did not win the popular
vote he got 37 percent good but he won
in the electoral college so thank
goodness for the electoral college that
helped end slavery good Wow explains you
know what if you're gonna eliminate
every institution that had its roots in
slavery you have to eliminate the
Democratic Party yeah because look at
the history over there on your side Juan
that wasn't too good it was the
Republican Party slavery if I could move
on though from that
yes it's true that a lot of people are
moving to States a lot of the Coast
California Florida Texas New York those
are really big states but at what one is
not how the founders intended but also
it could change yeah you know if you
could really like New York is seeing
population leave in droves because of
taxes I wish that will happen other
places these things have a way of
balancing out if you say the Senate is
the is tyranny that's why you have the
house or you have checks and balances
you have the White House you have the
Supreme Court you have other things one
saying that the Republicans you know
they would they rammed it home so hard
and the Democrats were a little soft
this is the first time I think
Republicans showed up to a gun fight
with a gun instead of a knife and the
voters are going to reward them for that
and the impeachment thing I completely
agree with you it's gonna fire up the
Republican base and the Democrats just
look crazy and extreme and after a while
the voters are going to say health care
education costs wages what does an
impeachment fight over a Supreme Court
justice do for me at all and I think the
Democrats are going to get way way
caught out they're not really focused on
what the actual people in this country
think the other thing is the Democrats
and the media looks so angry and hateful
and desperate and we're just flouting
all the rules in the standards of this
country the voters in America I believe
are going to look and say if the
Democrats get power back after the
midterms they're gonna go nuts with it
because we've seen how dangerous they
can be
out of power they would let you know
what you're missing here is Supreme
Court nominations mean something and I
think they mean something in political
terms Jesse I don't think there's any
doubt that people think that adds up
today with kavanah on the court if you
look at abortion rights in the country
you look at gun control you look at
voter rights in this country that
there's a Republican majority very
conservative on all those issues much
more open to putting well in the case of
abortion limits in the case of voting
rights limits and in the case of what
was the other one I mentioned
immigration they just they just going to
rubber stamp any conservative Democrats
actually have to elect people to
legislate and pass these laws rather
than using our judicial system
to do them no I don't now that you have
a court that's conservative that's
focused on the actual Constitution
rather than making law through the court
system in the Jews and making law Bagan
when you say wooden cable that's not
that's what happened they had to amend
the Constitution and view it not as a
strict construction about I'm talking
about not abiding by the Second
Amendment what do you guys do it you
guys like my idea that the Democrats
should put their money where their mouth
is and suspend due process for Democrats
is that a great solution this is a silly
talk genius because what this guy was he
had his life on the line if he was found
guilty is going to jail no this was not
about due process this was about a test
of character yeah exactly and Democrats
say that they want to be more cynical
like the Republicans I actually think
that this past two weeks is some the
most cynical like they're an extreme of
wanting to figure out a way to change
the system in order to win the other
thing is if they want to change the
electoral college it takes like
two-thirds of the Senate right and 348
states I mean they're wasting their time
if they're going to talk about
impeachment or the electoral college